you
oh this could maybe be it though oh come
on I want to see d5 d5 is close to
happening I'm pretty sure after Knight
f6 yes I think this this is maybe close
to a win this may actually be close to a
win you just have to believe me you will
just have to believe me if we see d5 oh
we're seeing d5 we are seeing it okay
the next phase is just to make sure I
could get this pawn up but he's attacked
let's do this c3 here and things might
be pretty good if you Castle yes I could
do this move right now I want to do it
right now I have the structure I want
here's the plan I've done this so many
times before
the plan is pot on h4 bishop on g5
Bishop takes pawn takes and then plant a
knight on f6 and then go for me you
follow that okay this bishop is more
aggressively placed usually it's on b7 I
need more development and I think that
it should start with
I'm not sure how it should start
let's go with this and see what it does
okay
see file will be opened up let's go with
this and see what it does
all right I have phase 1 phase 1 I need
to reinforce my Center ok
phase 2 is what exactly 1 2 3 4 5 you
know what this computer is ready to do
it's ready to take and then play Queen
before it just it just goes pawn hunting
and places pieces in your position and
it's very very uncomfortable so I'm
wondering about a3 just to keep this
Queen out
maybe it's more important to keep the
night out let's let's start going for my
night's journey I need to get some
development and sure enough we have that
Queen before yeah I figured you'd do
that okay
initially I was thinking Brooke b1 but
that's failing to Bishop d3 alright rook
b1 Bishop d3 a3 Queen b5 still pressure
um b2 still pressure on my rook maybe I
could do without this pawn I doubt it I
think I need to hang on to him and here
come the pieces here comes the pain
my knight is still going on his journey
both Knights are out of play
I don't want to trade Queens
oh you know what I should do I think
play rook here now the rook isn't going
to take I was thinking I want to
recapture and get my rook over in this
section of the board because it ties in
well when I get my knight on this square
about two minutes
it's gonna be a lot of pressure on the C
file maybe it's important to get rid of
one rook I don't know it's tough too
much activity for black
and yes I'll try the rook is gonna enter
though I just don't know how to activate
my queen it's a big problem Bishop here
and then get my king - G - I guess guess
here
Brook here's met with rooks III huh yeah
there is that move isn't there
yeah I'm just never I'm never getting my
I could do this Queen I'll get on that
diagonal though my night is now hit come
over here hitting at h2 oh yeah look at
that
ouch that's painful mmm that's very
painful what am I missing
we'll see soon oh what a nice mate
Queenie four oh I had a glimmer of hope
when the centre closed up like that it
just got too too active oh I wanted uh I
wanted it not to play this sometimes it
doesn't do this Knight move I mean it's
clearly the right thing to do and yeah
I've had this happen so many times let
me just show you the successful approach
that sometimes happens let's see this is
usually well not usually but this is
sometimes what I've experienced right
let me make some nothing moves sometimes
the bishop is here it does pass so
actually sometimes it moves this pawn we
have this sometimes it does these
pointless moves it'll even come over
here and then there's this stuff it's
like it does nothing actually I'm going
about it in the wrong way
Knight here
here and then here it's like it it gets
to this idea a bit too late or sometimes
doesn't even do it at all
let's just say it has no plan and just
kind of shuffles there's this sort of
stuff keep the knight out of there just
to illustrate my point here there's
these sacrifices okay let me just throw
it in there Knight here these sort of
things are available takes takes and
then it doesn't sacrifice back actually
in that case it would need to do that
I'd say right now it come over here and
then there's like these mate threats
available with the rook coming over you
could build it all up you don't you
don't necessarily have to throw the
knight into that f6 square right away
you could do more prep moves like King
g2 rook over here this sort of things
and I'm know I'm I know I'm making a lot
of passing moves for black but just to
illustrate the idea of the knight
jumping in here could be quite powerful
the Queen being on this diagonal which
is what I was trying to do in this past
game get that Queen on this diagonal so
she could come out in this direction but
it was it I always had to do it in a
very artificial way and by then it was
too late
tactics I was a resaw on f3 but I've
done that many times with success but
again more in a position where black
just is kind of moving about aimlessly
okay I am tired
you